a bill covering other big elements in
the biden agenda could be close to
getting a vote after months of
negotiations but democratic senator
kristen sinema has not promised her
support and that could torpedo the whole
plan scott mcfarlane is on capitol hill
scott good morning michelle good morning
to you after joe manchin struck a
surprise deal last week all eyes are now
on another moderate senate democrat
kirsten sinema of arizona who we've seen
huddling through the week with her
colleagues amid reports she's pushing
back on one of the tax provisions in
this bill which would scale back an
existing tax break for investment fund
managers some of whom have donated
significantly to cinema's campaign she
also wants to scale up money for drought
programs for the biden administration
and for congressional democrats this
would be a big victory less than a
hundred days till the midterm elections
the bill has potentially popular tax
breaks for people who buy energy
efficient appliances or fuel-efficient
cars also billions of dollars to extend
some health care subsidies for the
affordable care act in an effort to
lower some prescription drug costs and
an effort to try to lower the hulking
national debt with new taxes on some
corporations
democrats have been calling this the
inflation reduction act republicans
criticized that name and have told cbs
news raising taxes at a time of
inflation and possible recession is
potentially dangerous to the economy
david
scott thank you